well i'm joined now by a climate
scientist from the british antarctic
survey dr ella gilbert dr ella gilbert
good to see you thanks for joining us
this afternoon um so we've had we're
going into the second heatwave in just
over a month
can these heat waves that we've seen
this summer be attributed to climate
change
well we know that the climate science
has been saying that
climate change makes heat waves like
this more frequent it makes them hotter
and more intense and it also prolongs
them so this is exactly what we would
expect from a changing climate and in
fact a very rapid
attribution study which tries to detect
the kind of the fingerprint of climate
change in extreme weather events which
was done on last month's heat wave
showed that it was something like 10
times more likely to happen because of
climate change so it's under undeniable
that climate change is making these
sorts of extreme weather patterns happen
more often so the people that will say
but i remember plenty of hot summers in
the past this is no different
you're saying that this is actually
different
yeah i mean people often
reach for the example of 1976 for
instance and whilst we have experienced
hot
uh periods or heat waves in the past if
you look at the general pattern over
time you can see very clearly even just
from looking at the headlines in the
news and the media over the last few
decades that these sorts of occurrences
are happening more and more often you
know the hottest uh 10 years on record
have all been since 2000 and that should
really be testament to the fact that
these sorts of hot record-breaking
temperatures are happening more and more
frequently and a lot of countries have
signed up to try to get their emissions
down many of them by 2050 to try and
reach net zero that's as close to zero
emissions as possible to try to tackle
at the advances of climate change
to what extent has that been hampered in
recent months by russia's invasion of
ukraine are there many countries that
now reverting to using fossil fuels to
try to meet the gap that they're
experiencing
well of course it's these sorts of
geopolitical uh problems are
not naturally and necessarily at the
forefront of of people's minds and they
must be
approached uh urgently but i think what
we're missing in some senses is that
lots of the solutions to all of these
problems the cost of living you know
energy security climate change they can
all be solved by similar sorts of of uh
measures so you know if we move away
from fossil fuels not only does that
improve our energy security not only
does it help with the cost of living
because renewables are the cheapest form
of electricity generation but it also
helps with climate change so it's almost
like a win-win-win scenario if we start
doing that yes although some people will
say that's a longer-term plan because it
takes a time to put that kind of
infrastructure into place and then there
is a real need now and while we have
this ambition to get to net zero the
uk's target is 20 50 isn't it what would
happen to the climate at that point does
it stay the same as it is in 2050 or is
there any way of reversing some of the
effects that we've been seeing over
recent years
well what we do in climate science is
kind of
forecast a variety of different uh
possible outcomes and there are
certainly uh some ideas that we can get
to net zero by 2050 and then start to
reverse some of the damage that we've
done so far um of course that all
depends on our behavior now and until
2050 and after 2050 but it's certainly
possible to start to rectify some of the
problems that we've already caused and
of course it's a very long-term uh thing
that we're talking about here and it
requires a really concerted amount of
action from all over the world and all
parties and in the meantime
how much more likely is it now that
we'll see summers like this again in
future
unfortunately it's likely to become more
frequent unless we really pull out all
the stops and do everything that we can
to avoid worsening climate change and we
are inevitably going to see some more
warming because it takes a little while
for the climate to kind of catch up with
the emissions of greenhouse gases that
we've already produced so we are
definitely going to see more
frequent and more intense uh extreme
events like this but that doesn't
necessarily mean it will be the case
forever if we
implement meaningful climate action and
we start to reduce our emissions and
reverse that damage that we've done then
it will start to improve and future
generations will have a hopefully a more
rosy picture